[Music]
I am very frugal because I would love to
be able to not work past the age of uh
50 and I'm on track for that as long as
I sort of freeze my spending where it is
now
and I'm always sort of torn because I
also would like to live a little better
sometimes the value that you bring
Josephine to the world that work is not
something to escape but it's something
that you can actually enjoy and find
something that you find meaning from now
I agree with you I wouldn't want to be
paycheck to paycheck feeling like I'm
still scraping by and that I'm still so
nervous that I'm not going to be able
but at this point in your life you could
because how old are you I'm 32 okay so
at this point in your life Josephine I
mean you have a solid 20 25 years past
that 50 point 52 55 that you can put
away some serious money